All right. We ready? All right. Hey,
what's going on is bill bird is
time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and a,
I'm not checking in on you this week.
Usually I check in on you to
see how your week's going,
but occasionally I'll have a guest on
at which point I'm talking to them and
hopefully this fills up your ride home.
Uh,
I am with the one and only the legend
from the San Francisco area from Prime
Primus. Mister Les Claypool. How are
you sir? Uh, I am well, I am fantastic.
You just got over it. You literally just
landed and you came right over here,
which is, you're just a hardest working.
I'm in jet setters. They say. Yeah,
it's like an Irish setter in a
jet. How was your uh, southwest?
I'm going to guess flight down. No, I took
one of the, I've never done this before.
I took a, uh, it's called, uh, I
think it's called jet suite. Oh,
and that's one of those app jet
things. Yeah. I don't know. I have my,
my guy out there set it up.
I've never done such a thing was it,
now here's a big question that
everyone's going to want to know.
Did you have to go through any sort of
security? Do you just walk on the fucker?
I walked on the fucker. Um,
big box like bugs bunny.
So you got there earlier
than I needed to get at,
which was like 45 minutes and I sat in a
little lounge and I ate some beef Jerky,
which I have some beef jerky if
you would care for some dirty,
you know what I think I'm going to pass.
I just had a bunch of shit food that
I shouldn't have ate and the uh,
and the Goddamn lounge area here.
I should've gone beef jerky.
If I could have held out,
I could have had a nice protein
because I had an ask Jim Beam, uh,
you know, convenience store, pack
of pack of Cherokee. But uh, I,
I hop right on the plane. It
was, it wasn't anything fancy.
It's not like it's a fancy thing.
It's just a convenient, you know,
you don't have to, it just
looks like a plane, but you get,
it looks like a fancy planning. But
inside it looks like a regular plain with,
you know, you know, sort of cramped seats
and all that. But it was, it was cool.
I enjoyed the notion of not having to,
um,
be scrutinized by, by a guy and take
my shoes off and all that one. Right.
So that all part is perfect. But they,
do they do any sort of screening?
Like how do they know you're cool? Ah,
I don't, I don't think they ever did.
I don't think they ever,
that was it.
I don't think that was ever a
concern that I was cool. Yeah.
I'm just saying like if I'm a terrorist,
it's a fond the airline. No, no, no,
I'm not, I mean, as far as like,
I don't mean literally cool.
I mean as far as like the reason
why we all go through the security.
So now you have this thing
that's just generally,
if you have the cash and you
can download a fucking app,
you can just get on this damn plane.
I'm assuming it's, it's, it was my,
it was my virgin run, so I'm, did you,
was there anything, was there any that go,
any of that concern is you got on there?
Did you do a quick turn
around to see if, uh, okay.
Just trucker hats? Uh, I it did not.
There was a woman that came walking
in and I'm assuming she had some form
enhanced buttocks, like, oh,
whether it's the pants that have the
padding in it or she had some sort of, um,
surgical, yes. Because it just,
it didn't look like it didn't look
like reality. It doesn't move. Like,
first of all, the legs
move, the ass doesn't,
and then on top of that is the
legs don't match the ass. Yeah.
It looked like it looked like something
when you were a kid, you would draw,
you know, fun House Mirror. It
didn't, it didn't look like real.
It didn't look like reality. I'm just
going to leave it at that. Right.
So that was the only thing she knows.
That could've been a bomb
smuggled in that form of fashion.
That was the only thing I saw that
seemed irregular. Did you shame or no?
No. Why would I? How would I shame
her? What would you do? I'd be like,
do you think your phone,
anybody with that fake ass?
Could somebody please
make sure you really know.
What I would do is I would be a,
I would be a coward about it
is I wouldn't say anything.
I would snicker to myself
and I were talking about on
my podcast and my standup.
Okay, well there you go. You've
heard of the cowardly lion.
I'm the cowardly comedian, comedian. I
like it. That's exactly what I am. Good.
So I know you're a busy man and you,
you don't have time to just be flying
around and just sitting down and talking
to some fucking Middle Act here
who shames people with fake asses.
There is a reason you are a man on a
mission here. I'm man on a mission.
You have a new mission. I'm curious,
you are here to promote things as,
as most people who are very
artistically inclined. Uh, yeah. I,
I started asking you about your new
album that you did with Sean Lenin called
the monolith of full house eight foe,
the monolith of Phobos.
That was a whole album. That was our
first album. That's your first one.
So this new Lyme in the limpid. Well
that's our, that was our, an EAP.
We did our, the new album
is, is, is, is different.
The new album's called south of reality.
I literally, before we turned it on,
I asked you what is your new album?
[inaudible] previous albums. Oh,
did I say that? Jesus crossed.
All right. What's it called? Uh,
it's called south of reality.
South. The reality. Yeah. Okay.
This is a nod to a slayer. They'd south
that heaven. So you south the reality.
So I didn't realize that
we were nodding slayer,
but I do enjoy nodding slayer on occasion.
Um,
I have to say this album,
um,
I've never had such a
difficult time naming,
nor coming up with the artwork
for an album as really we did.
Is that something that in the past
is this come easy for the, yeah,
they usually just, you know, flip pork,
soda, how that's going to be an appetite.
You know, these things just
Frizzell Friday they just
kind of, um, but this one,
you know, perhaps it's
because of the, you know,
both Sean and I are very opinionated,
but we just never,
we never could come up with a title that
will really set the tone or the artwork
as, as well. It, it, it took a long time,
but you haven't got the artwork here,
but it's,
it's actually,
it's one of the best album we that I've
been a health card. No, no. Very cool.
You know what your mind, even when you
just said your pork Sodi like some,
that's got to be an album title.
Yes. That reminds me, David,
tell David tell we'll call them,
will text me with like the most brilliant
joke that no one could think of other
than him. And there'll be like, do you
have a joke like this? And it's like,
no date. Nobody has a joke like that.
It's like, why would you like pork soda?
Who Comes, who comes up with that? Maybe,
maybe Beck Beck had some new pollution
and stuff like that. Like Jeff Beck? No,
the other back. Yeah, I
know the rapper. Um, hey,
so is that what comedians do they call
each other and say, do you have a joke?
Like if you're concerned, if you're
concerned of like sometimes, uh,
I don't know you've ever written a song,
just came to simple and your dislikes.
Then I hear this in a fucking
elevator or something.
It's the same thing with like,
just pretty much every prime as song.
It'd be probably music.
Oh yeah.
We got up there on the screen. That's
what the modern technologies, okay.
South the reality. All right, let's
go through this. Uh, you know,
this is not a visual medium here
for people. So what am I looking at?
That appears to be some sort of insect,
um,
does not appear to be on this planet,
but he definitely seems to be dealing
with some sort of global warming issue
here. It looks like he's at the
polar ice caps and it's melting.
It's got sneakers on.
I like that.
And he's looking into some sort of like
your interpretation of compact. Yes.
Is putting on taking the shine off
his nose. Um, that would be a flea.
It's supposed to be a flea. Okay. Um,
because we have a song called like
fleas. And so, uh, the flea made the,
made the cut.
Basically what happened was we w we
were bouncing artwork off each other's
Sean's and artist.
I'm an artist,
we work with a bunch of
different artists and um,
Sean did the drawings for the, for
the, for the first album. And um,
somehow the notion came about if let's,
let's find an artist to do something
like one of those old Saifai paperbacks
from sixties and seventies.
And I stumbled across this piece of
art and we couldn't find the artist.
And we looked and looked and finally
found this guy and he's this Japanese
fellow that Sean ended up knowing about.
And he used to do Omni magazine
covers and whatnot. And, and he,
after my brother used to read many
renditions, he came up with this.
So there it is. Now, how does
that connect with the music?
I guess I have to listen to the album.
Like this looks like some old school
stuff where you just do like the,
that kind of drug that makes you happy.
You know,
none of that crazy stuff that makes you
think he can fly and sometimes done a
lot of drugs. I ain't nothing he
can fly. It kind of makes you happy,
don't you think? The notion,
the notion of flight,
um Oh do I get that out of the fleet?
This right here is why I
don't go to museums because
it just makes me feel dumb.
I just like,
there's no scoreboard there.
I can't tell what's
going on and then I just,
it just ends up making me feel dumb.
I think if you listen to the record
you'll get a notion to what some of this
stuff is.
Like fleas is the closing song,
which is a song like fleet.
The line is like fleas on the back of
a dog eventually will be shaken off,
which is the notion that parasitic
man and eventually, you know,
Mother Nature's trying to kick us off
the off the planet cause we're just
screwing everything up. And so Shawn said,
we're like fleas on the back of a dog.
So it was, it was a water will rise
up. It was a moment where, you know,
I had this lyric and,
and I read it to him and he said,
oh well we're like fleas
on the back of a dog.
And then that became another portion
that became the chorus. So that's cool.
That's where the Claypool, Lennon
lyrical cooperative comes into play.
I was thinking yesterday,
I was out in Santa Monica and I just
looked at the ocean, how big it was.
It's just like, it's coming
for us. Oh, it's calming.
Um, would you say that you
are addicted to touring? No,
cause every time I see is if you're not
making an album bank account is addicted
to touring. Oh, is that what it
is? I got a kid in college, man,
you gotta you gotta keep saying guys, you
know I do get in legit. What was that?
Did you can't get into school legit or
did you pull that showbiz stuff that
happened? If it was a bit of a handle
down here, how many Cox I had to suck the
um, well the urine and legit, we're not
dealing with chimps here. He's, he's,
I wasn't sure if you Photoshop his head
onto like, wait, what? What did you,
what were you saying? People. Oh,
you're talking about the latest
thing we're buying. So there,
I mean there was some Hollywood
celebrities that got in trouble.
They were photoshopping their
nonathletic kids had on top of it,
like some sort of Lloyd it up guy. And
then the football coach would be in on,
it'd be like, Hey, here's a great new
year. They think like a white kid,
put it on some Samoan kids body torso
or something. And next thing you know,
he's the starting linebacker allegedly
potential for the USC Trojans.
See I should have done that
because you know he will,
he's going to an art college so
there's no sports whatsoever there.
But just the notion that we could,
we could have applied that Salvador Dali
weird mustaches and the beard thing and
just Photoshop it onto his, uh,
his face and they'd be like, wow,
look how creative this
stuff like that. He's, he's,
he's trying to get in on
a sports scholarship to a
school that has no sports. Um,
no,
he's an artist.
He's going to Laguna College of art and
design and he's learning to make video
games.
He's been into it since he was like 14.
He has been taking courses
in the summertime at cow
and Stanford and went on.
He's all about it. That's his
whole, Oh, so you're out here raw.
You're out here hustling.
But being a great dad,
he could share his dream comes true.
I'm a good dad. You are. There you go.
It's one of my better,
my better accomplishments.
I wasn't sure how you're
going to take the compliment.
A lot of people can't take compliments.
I'll take that compliment. I,
I take pride in what I've done
with my kids. I'm a good guy. Damn.
Damn good father.
Um,
are you going to leave three cigarettes
out on their foreheads? Well, you gotta,
you gotta you know you to
make a statement, you've got
to let him know who's in charge.
You've got to set those parameters.
You set the tone. Uh, we are going to
be seeing the tour bus on this. Uh,
you can do on a run right now.
You're doing some dates.
So we just promoting the album.
Uh,
I was just told to come down here
and talked to him, talked to Vaughn,
Birmingham and I, here I
am. Um, yeah, I, you know,
I have friends down here and just kind
of popped down here. Just come to say,
oh okay. But I know we have a record
and we'll get ready to go on tour.
The records new, we did Cole bear
last week, week before, you know,
we're out there see a slumming it too
or out there starting to shake hands and
kiss babies and all that one.
Not.
So the press too are starting to
wind down now that you're on my, uh,
he was starting to do podcasts, so wine
to nap. I think this is the beginning.
This is,
we're about to start touring and I,
the thing is is this year was supposed
to be mellow because last year was a big
prime usher. We did the longest two or
I've ever done in my, I saw you guys,
I saw you in Austin. It was incredible.
Austin and Austin city limits.
I absolutely love that show.
And I three times in my life
I was supposed to see you
and some bs came up on my
business and I wasn't able
to go three fucking times.
And finally our paths crossed on the road.
And uh,
I was able to see you guys in Austin.
I W I performed some
dump the night before.
Then I went to the beautiful
place you guys were at and uh,
I got to see the show and it was
absolutely incredible. Like the way you,
I don't know all this stuff that you do,
the way you put together the music with
the visual is just a whole experience
that makes me wish I tried
psychedelics at some point in my life.
So you've never tried psychedelics
at any? No, I, I'm always,
I've always been like a late bloomer,
so I figure I'll try and do the thing
with your cousins where you'd hold your
breath,
hyperventilate and then they squeeze you
until you pass out and smack your head
on the ground. And none of them
know. I did see some kids at school.
There was this big thing, like we
didn't understand how the body worked.
So there was, we thought this was
amazing that basically what's,
you'd sit there and someone
would grab both your jugglers,
either side of the neck and just
squeeze them. Holy Mackerel. Yeah.
And kids would just fallen over.
And I or did you grow up? Uh,
the suburbs of Boston.
Ah,
it was the 80s like there wasn't a
lot of information out to m domain,
my neighborhood. Yeah. So we just, we went
straight to methamphetamine. Oh, you did?
Well, I didn't, but you
went to Elliot. I forgot.
I tried weed for the first time when I
was like almost 40. So I think of it,
I'll try. I remember saying I get it.
When I finally got high I was like, oh,
I get it. I get it. Um, but
it's not something you partake.
I think the way that I'm wired booze is a,
I should probably smoke weed
because I'm probably too wound up.
But I relate to booze,
like how it makes you feel.
And also I feel like there's this a
trajectory to it that I understand.
Like I had one beer,
here I am,
okay now I've had to when this
amount of time and now we've,
now we go up to the second
floor where that shit,
it's just like you do it and like
nothing happens until it does.
And then it's just like someone dropped
a fucking piano on your head depending
on the potency of it.
And then you start falling and it's
just like how deep is this fucking hole
where with drinking you can
kind of be like, oh, okay.
Hey, people go into the hall.
I'm the drinking too. You
can do that. You can listen.
I'm not trying to get in the
way of anybody's fun here.
I'm just saying the way I'm wired,
where I would drinking,
I can see the staircase down to the
basement where with like psychedelics,
I feel like I can maybe see,
I would think anyway,
like my never done second to I guess
what's some fucking weed though?
I've ate wheat a couple of times
and never eat weed. That's, that's,
that's the worst. I mean I've, I saw
the last time I read, I saw the light.
I saw the light, the hold it and I
literally said, don't go into the light.
You have kids. It was one of my
kids were little and I how many?
How many milligrams was it? I have no
idea. I was, I didn't even want it.
We are in a van touring the,
the,
the east coast with one of my little
bands and a couple of the guys.
Somebody had given us some
Claypool's bucket of Bernie brains,
the frog brigade and JC who,
who's just a,
it's just a human bong was
eating all these brownies,
him and a couple of other guys and I was
just hungry and we were driving to the
hotel late at night and I was
like, all right. He's like, man,
these things are a hell of a week.
I was, all right, let me have one.
I'm just going to eat it
because I'm hungry. And by
the time we got to the hotel,
I could barely move. And
it was intense. Yeah. I,
the first time I ever ate
wheat was like that. I, uh,
my girlfriend at the time brought over
a tray of brownies that her roommate had
made and they will probably about the
size of like a bathroom tile, you know,
big square things, right? So she eats half
of one. I go, well, how much should I eat?
She goes, well, you're bigger than
me. You should eat a whole one.
So I eat a whole one. And then was
sitting there and looking back,
I was getting high, but I
didn't, it was coming on slow.
So I didn't feel like I felt anything.
She goes and we were going out. She goes,
well, your bigger, why don't you,
why don't you have another one? Yes.
So I had another one, the slippery
slope. I still didn't feel anything.
And then as we walked out the door,
I hate her other half.
So I had two and a half,
then got in a car and went to Newark
Airport because we will go into Costa Rica
and it hit me right at the fucking
airport and it was one of the, uh,
at first it was hilarious.
And then the paranoia came in and
by the time I got onto the plane,
I just wanted to stand up
and admit everything and just
fucking get it over with.
But um,
probably for like a 12
hour period it seemed,
I felt like, you know, when your
foot falls asleep really bad.
I felt like there was a ball
of that sitting on my head
and I remember thinking,
oh, people say I got baked. I
got fried and I was thinking,
I'm literally frying my brain
right now and I, I didn't enjoy it.
It for like two days, I was
like, we'd hung over. Yeah.
And that was the end of that. No, it's
making, it's actually making me nauseous.
Just hearing the story
cause I know that feeling.
Yeah. I just, why I don't eat,
I just remember there was,
and I was a big pot smoker for many,
many years, but he still likes to smoke.
I don't like putting smoke into my lungs
ballgame. But you're a wise man. Yeah.
Yeah. But then I smoked cigars every
10 days or so once every 10 days.
I tried to, again, it'd be a week and a
half. I have one, I dunno, red hour back.
Look for a long time. He used to
smoke them every time they won a game.
He won a lot of games. He
lived a lot of years. Um,
how did you, how did you end up
meeting up with, uh, Sean Lennon?
Does he have any sort of musical
background, by the way? Not much.
I think his dad was a
transmission mechanic. Oh,
that was my dad's, sorry. Um,
uh,
his band ghost of the saber tooth tiger
opened for Primus on a tour we were
doing with dinosaur jr and
we just hit it off. Actually,
he and my son hit it off
right away because my son's
like one of these guys that
just absorbs random bits of
knowledge and then, you know,
regurgitate some to people to,
you know, get these conversations.
Did he get that from one
way more is way more.
He gets into all this nerdy
stuff and Sean's the same way.
Sean's like Encyclopedia Brown.
It's unbelievable. You get,
he can get him going
on just about anything.
And so they're just
sitting there a little bit,
a little bit of talking about the cosmos
are talking about, you know, whatever.
And um, so then, uh,
this was on one of the tours and then
Sean and I hit it off and we just kind of
started jamming one day.
I have so little dough bro base that
I carry around and fiddle around with
backstage. Oh, what is that?
It's, it just looks like,
you know what a dough bro Guitar it looks
like with a resonator, with a senior,
with the big, uh, it's like, uh, it's
like an acoustic her, but it has a, uh,
a big chrome resonator in
the middle of it. Okay. Um,
and they tend to sound a little more
metallic and I have a basis like that.
So I was toiling away on it and he comes
over with his acoustic and we start
trying and then I started realizing, wow,
this guy's playing, he's not playing,
uh, just uh, uh,
predictable counterparts to what I
was doing or playing along with me.
He was pointing some very interesting
stuff and we've made a habit of it just
kind of getting together and
jamming. And I said, Hey,
I want you to come out to Rancho relaxo
at my place and see what we can come up
with Rancho relaxo. And we did.
How does that, how does that work?
I've always been fascinated because I'm
such a huge music fan and was not given
the gift. Unfortunately or fortunately I
think I've seen you play drums. I know,
but I mean, yeah, it's like Dad
rock. You know what I mean? If you,
if you give me all the answers
to the test, he is like the,
it's like the is the mainstay
of the Australian economy.
It's because their dad
rockers, you know, I, I'm just,
I'm just saying one time I ever jam with
somebody and they actually had their
own riffs and then I had to do what
you were just saying Sean was doing and
there was no answer to the test.
It's like, hey bill, you know,
cause before it was just, Oh,
John Bond and played this,
let's just fucking work
on this til I can play it.
Which of course I never was able to,
but I could fake it. But this one,
I actually got together with somebody
like, hey, here's my creative ideas.
Can you creatively add to this?
I just kept playing the same.
I think my face literally turned red. I
was saw, I was like, wow, I knew I sucked.
I didn't realize I suck this bad.
So that fascinates me that
you got together with Shawn
and what he was playing
cod you ear like, oh, what is
this guy saying? How do you,
how did you learn how to
like a free yourself up?
Like what point did you feel
at you? Like, Hey, I'm, I'm,
if I'm, I'm in in this mood,
so now when I pick up my bass,
I can play the mood that I'm in.
Like I feel like great musicians,
you guys are literally just like
talking with the instruments.
So like the way I can be like, you
know, how was your day? Oh Man,
fucking song off the boat and I
am down here and this is my tone.
You guys can do that with
your instruments. Like how,
how do you learn how to fucking do that
blows my mind. Well, I mean I've always,
I would have said for a long time,
you know, playing music, it's a con,
it's a conversation and interacting
with jamming with other musicians,
you're having a conversation.
Some musicians are really great
at reading a speech, you know, or,
or classical musicians that can only
read the written page. Right. I've,
I've had people come into the studio
and violinists or whatever, say, hey,
you know, jam on this movie. What do you
mean, you know, where's the written pay?
Yes. And I would assume it's very
similar to what you're doing. You know,
you can go out on stage and just
tell the jokes that are on the page.
Or you can tell the jokes on the page
and throw in a little zippity do in
between or, or take off on a, on a
tangent, a or full straight improv.
Uh, I'm sure he had done it.
All of those. It is the same.
But the thing about what fascinates
me is with, with stand up. Okay.
It's like, uh, all I'm doing is talking.
So you come, you know, from
the beginning, Mama, dad day,
you start talking and everybody like
write us right now, just talking.
You're just listening to me
and then you're reacting to it.
So you already know how to do
that. So as a calm, a comedian,
all I have to do is make that leap to,
uh,
you know, making it funny.
And then of course, you know,
blocking out the fact that there's
a bunch of people staring at you,
which is the weirdest
thing ever in a year.
And see now you're saying things that
to me are, are frightening. You know,
and I've always been fascinated with
standup comics because the notion of going
out and,
and doing a bit over and over,
you and I talked about this a
little bit once you said, well,
I can I move it around, I am probably do
this and I'm listening and I get that,
but I can go out and stand in front
of tens of thousands of people,
hundreds of thousands of people,
um,
with is if I got a base in front of me,
you know, I kind of, my base, I can do it,
you know, but going out there without that
thing and I would die, you know, I, I,
I don't know I could do it, you know,
but maybe, well, maybe that's what it is.
Maybe it just, I dunno, I just,
I just think that that's the most
fascinating thing ever. That like, uh, um,
because I had a period in my
standup where I was literally,
I would just memorize my jokes and
went up and did my jokes and then
occasionally I would try a new one and
was his big fucking moment. Like, okay.
How was that for he was that new jokes?
Terrifying.
Terrifying. How was it received? Oh,
most time. In the beginning of it,
it didn't do well.
And then I would get panicked,
which would make my brain go blank and
then I couldn't remember my act and then
dry mouth and then it
just would all go to shit.
But like I would just
by continuing to bomb,
like if for musicians who are listening
to this, you keep going after that,
continuing to bomb. That's that to
me, that's the big hurdle right there.
Uh, I don't know who said it first, but
the, uh, this is the best way to put it.
Like a,
the comics for the most part,
that to make it or whatever,
or become pros of quitting.
It never dawns on you to quit
because that's what makes sense.
It would make sense that if
you felt that horrible feeling,
you would be like,
I don't ever want to do this again,
which is what you feel as a comedian.
But if you're a comedian as a person,
you feel,
but as a comedian you,
you don't think you think, I don't,
I'm, I'm still going to go and do this.
I just don't want that to happen
again. And then that's, that's the,
the thing that makes you nervous and
make sure live on stage of like, fuck,
is that thing going to happen tonight?
But is there that element of, okay,
I ducked, I ducked at, wait a minute,
I just got a great seven iron shot.
You know what I mean? Is there that,
oh, absolutely. Absa fucking blue there.
And so that's, that's what
it is. It's that getting, uh,
getting a laugh. Uh, yeah.
And I mean, you literally,
in the beginning you just
living laugh to laugh.
I remember that one guy in the crowd,
that one guy,
I heard him laugh or that comic
who's actually a pro, said, hey,
good job or good stuff. And then
yeah, I'll soon into into to this.
Did you get the, to get that? The first
time I really got a good one was a,
there was a comic,
uh,
Mike McDonald and it's not the guy a
rest his soul just passed away in Canada.
It was a out of the Boston scene and
I was in this comedy competition,
the big radio station WBCN,
which I'm sure it promoted, uh,
sailing the seas way
back when. Um, and uh,
they used to have this,
this thing called the WBCN a comedy riot
and it was at stitches comedy club and
it was to try and find, you know,
the best up and coming Boston, uh,
comic. I mean there's, this scene was just
increase. I mean, I came at the tail end,
I missed it, but it started in
the 80s that BCN would do that.
And it was just like, it was fucking
insane if you, if you won that thing.
And then of course there was the curse
of the ride if you made it or whatever.
So anyways,
in 1993,
the last year of it and stitches
clothes, like the week after, and I, uh,
I was, um, I entered the
contest and um, the night,
my night, it's like if you won
unite, then you went to the finals.
So there was like a qualifying and
then you had unites of the night.
This Guy Mike McDonald was hosting it.
I went up and did my bullshit and then
went over and went well and sat down at
the bar. I was still working at the
dental office with my dad. And, uh,
he came off stage and you walked over
to me and he just goes, uh, he just,
he just looked at me dead serious.
So typical pro comic didn't laugh at all
or anything, just look to me. He goes,
look, he goes, uh, I don't know what
you're doing, but keep doing it.
And that's all he said.
That's all I remember him saying.
And I remember being like,
wow,
I saw that guy on fucking MTV and he's
hosting the Rye was the biggest thing
ever.
And then that was a thing over the next
year and a half of sometimes doing okay
sometimes having a moment of killing
and then most of the times bombing.
That was just something that I hung onto.
That Guy Mike McDonald said,
I don't know what you're doing but keep
doing it. So if you hadn't got that,
that little nugget.
Yeah,
that's the thing that scares you
because I was thinking the other day,
I remember that, you know,
being an entertainer, we,
we work on those nights
when everybody stays home.
So it's kind of cool during the week
when they have to fucking go to work and
shit. But then all of a sudden, you know,
the holidays come around and all that
and everybody's gathering around eating,
fucking drinking eggnog and having the
Norman Rockwell scene and you've got to
grab your gear.
I got to fucking put on my stupid
sport coat to go do a do a show.
I remember the first time having that
feeling was football season. And you know,
still living back in Massachusetts and
this is back when you actually had a fall
before it just went from January to July.
It's kind of seems like the weather
now. And um, it was just that perfect,
crisp, cold football, whether I
was still living at home, you know,
just got out of college and my
parents are making a great meal.
They had some friends
over and we were watching,
I think a BC was playing Notre Dame
and it was this big thing to Catholic
schools and both teams were ranked
and it was going to be great.
And I had a fucking show and I had to
go down to Rhode Island to go down into
some fucking bar that wasn't
a comedy club. I knew it
was going to be a hell Gig.
And I remember saying to my older
brother being like, yeah, man, I don't,
I don't know man. I don't, I don't, I
don't think I want to go to this and blah,
blah blah. What do you think he would
think it would be bad if I just didn't,
and I was booked on the show.
I was going to like cancel it and thank
God he just sat there and he listened.
He's like, is that, I don't know
man. I think he should go, should go.
And I went and I remember
it sucked going out,
getting into my piece of Chez us old
fucking Ford truck and I got into it and
then once I got on the highway it just
started making sense like, yeah, yeah.
Thank, what the fuck was I thinking? What
else do I have? I suck at everything.
I was terrible in school. This is the
only thing I want. Why, why did you know?
It was just my first experience. That
was, I was sorta just like, uh, I dunno,
I'd never lived on my own or anything
was sort of me having a kick.
My brother helping me kick me out of the
nest a little bit and I went down there
and um, so those are two
things I think about a lot. If,
if that could be a good show. No. Yeah,
it older brother, younger brother,
older, but no, it wasn't a good show.
It was a, a I did. Okay. I think I did,
but no, none of them are good shows.
In the beginning it was, it was, uh,
it was surviving. It was all, it was
like my first like year and a half,
like very rare would there be like
open mics in an actual comedy club.
It was mostly a lot of, you know, Boston
area was a lot of Chinese restaurants,
sports bars where they turned down
the sound of the fucking Bruins game,
but they would leave it on,
he says perform at the, uh,
the 90 nines and restaurant
and Bill Ricka, Massachusetts.
And um, you know, I,
I spaghetti Freddy stay in a basement.
I've played like some shitty places.
Um, but I still, I've listened
to what you're saying and
I go, man, that's, that's,
those are just some big ass hurdles for
me that I'm not sure I would have been
able to go in and play in Spaghetti. Eddie
is, or Chinese restaurants, whatever.
But the notion too, I was going to ask
you, cause I heard you say, Oh, uh,
the dentist's office, you worked with your
data at the dentist's office. Yeah. Um,
so how supportive was he and your
family to what you are pursuing?
Totally, totally supportive. Like my
parents were really cool where, you know,
they did what they did and they
didn't pressure anybody to do,
they definitely stress the college
education, but there was just like,
like everyone in my family does
something completely different.
Um, so you just, I dunno,
there's this weird,
my family's weird, it's really like
loving, but everybody's a total loner.
So it's like love is like implied,
but it's definitely there.
If you were to look at it,
it looked like the Brady bunch,
but there was all kinds of,
you know, like most families,
they had a lot of things going
on there. But the, uh, the,
the thing that I, I, you
know, as you become a parent,
I think what you do is you,
like, you look at all the great
stuff your parents said. He like,
I'm keeping all that and then there'll
be like two or three things that you'd
like to adjust. But one of the things
that I am definitely going to keep is,
um, that thing that my parents
didn't judge me then I,
I wanted to get out of
going to a regular college,
go to more of a performance school.
They started doing radio that I got into
stand up and they would totally 100%
supportive. They never thought in
a, never said anything of like,
well Jesus Christ, what if you don't make
it, you gotta be fucking destitute. Um,
which was a period in my thirties that I
had to deal with when I didn't have any
representation or sleeping on a Fuckin
Futon, but I never gave her the, Oh, hey,
you know, it's, you've been working hard
at this, but you might want to, you know,
they're like, you know, you know, for a
salesman over at the Chevy dealer, no.
You know, it was a dick.
The, uh, the, our butcher,
he was an asshole when he just found
out that he and my mother was all proud
going like, Yay, he's over
at Emerson College and he's
majoring in communication.
He might have a career in
radio and he reigned for her.
Mother just said, he guys,
Hey, he goes, I don't know.
Everybody wants to be the staff.
Like that's what he said.
And I remember looking at him and
his bloody fucking apron. He would,
you were standing
there when I was just like,
fuck this guy fucking cutting
up poor God bless him.
Cutting up the pork chops and shit.
But like the fuck is,
we never even had a butcher.
Yeah, you got to have a portrait.
We didn't have a butcher.
You just go to this store and there'd
be some cellophane and away you went.
All right, well here's my thing. But the,
but the great thing was was
all I had to deal with was me.
I didn't have to figure out how
to get along with three, four,
the fucking people and getting
a van and deal with somebody.
I found with group traveling where
the weed comes in and that's where,
because I was not a pot smoker prior to
getting in that van with this foot odor
and the hippiest right. It was, I'm
serious. Like, I smoked some dope and,
and high school. In fact, uh,
uh, lots of different story. But,
um, tell it I could. My Dad,
he, my dad was like, we got,
we've always gotten along very well,
but my dad was very young when I was born.
He was 19.
And my dad was like the Fonz,
he was like a cross between the Fonz
and Dennis Weaver, you know, and um,
but he was not, he, he was married.
He used to brag that when he was 19,
he had a mortgage payment, a car
payment, a payment on a washer and dryer.
He was a transmission mechanic and he
had a wife and a baby boy at 19. Um,
so needless to say,
he was not the type of guy that in
whatever year that was was running around
smoking dope or any of
that stuff he wanted. Yeah,
he wanted to beat up
those guys. So, um, uh,
so when they found the tiniest little
speck of weed in this film container in my
bedroom when I was in high school, I got
a lot of trouble for that. I'm sorry.
He called the cops on me.
Um, he did it to scare me.
He called the local guy that he knew
and it scared the shit out of me. Um,
and that was actually sold to me
by Kirk Hammett, by the way. Um,
but no way. Yeah, we went to high school
together. He used to smell, sound me weed,
but I was not like a big weed smoker.
I just kind of smoked to hang and be cool
and all the musicians, you know. But I,
I didn't really enjoy it cause I,
it was a very similar to you.
I was a tall, skinny guy. And when
he would hit me and just, you know,
I couldn't control my brain.
I didn't like it so much.
So it wasn't until I crawled in that
van in my early twenties with all these
dudes and we start driving across the
country and the joint comes passing by me
and pink Floyd animals is on the
stereo. Right? Then I went, okay,
I'll have some of that.
And it made the roads so much sweeter
and I became a pot smoker after that for
many, many years. For decades.
I've got to ask you a question. What,
where are these fucking high schools?
How was your musicians like you
listen to guns and roses. It's like,
oh slash went to high
school with Steven Adler.
You listened to the Chili peppers
and it's just like a flea.
When I went to school with a blanket on
this lead singer's name Anthony, right.
They just like, like a whole
fucking band. It's just like,
like this kids walking around,
like being like, oh yeah,
the bass player from a,
from a Primus was in my ips
class. And uh, the guitarist from
Metallica, I took Jim with
him. Like, what, where the
fuck are these high schools?
Well, I mean, I grew up in, in an area,
I was born in Richmond Panol,
Elsa Bronte,
which is a North East Bay San Francisco
area. I mean, it's basically it.
So it's all, it's all blue collar.
You know, where I went to school,
you said you would say you've taken the
test. I'm, I'm taking that. I'm not, well,
I'm going to take the test or
are you gonna take this call?
I took the test and the test was to
see what job you are going to get at
standard oil.
You know,
Larry Lalanne from Primus took
the test and he did very well,
but he said screw that.
And he went off and play death metal in
a band called possessed. Um, but that's,
that's where we grew
up. And so, uh, I dunno,
I mean Kirk was in my, my Algebra
class with Mr. Kelly and Kirk who have,
you know, he had this dirty white tee
shirts and big thick pop bottle glasses.
And he sat behind me just
divvying up dime bags and looking
at guitar magazines. And, uh,
so I remember it because I would always
be singing these songs and he said,
hey Claypool, hey man, you
want to come sing for my band?
And I was too bashful to sing.
I can barely sing now.
But, um, so when it came down
to it, I, I couldn't do it, but,
and then I met this other
guy who needed a bass player.
And so I begged and pleaded my dad, hey,
let me, cause we had no money. So let me,
I know a guy who has a base for $30 let
me, let me buy it and let me some money.
And he said, well, if we're going
to do this, let's do this right.
Let's go see all over at house music.
And we love that there wasn't a
guitar center's back then. Yeah,
well I mean there was, but they were
not where we live. You know what I mean?
It's just more like local because I used
to go to Norfolk county music. Yeah.
So we went to Alice music
and my bought a fender, uh,
Memphis p based copy copy of
a fender p Bass. And you know,
I was going to give us a good deal and
I'm not sure Al gave my dad a great deal,
but I ended up,
I had this base and I had to pull weeds
all summer and work for people and what
not to pay off this base, but
I was instantly in a band. But
what's the thing, if you
were a bass player, you, it
was easy to get into a bank.
Everybody wanted to be Eddie van Halen.
Nobody wanted to play the bass.
So it was like, Hey, and bus. It only had
four strings. I figured it'd be easier.
And, uh, I was instantly in a
band and a way I went. But Kirk,
he was,
he also had this band called exodus,
which went on to be exodus one of the
premiere metal bands of the world.
Um, uh, after he left Metallica, I mean,
after he left exit exodus to Metallica,
but we just had a good, well,
music community,
where are we,
where we'd all get together
and jam at Keggers and whatnot.
And that's just what you did. That's
a, that's that's, I don't know,
I came from more of a jock town, so none
of that stuff existed. And we weren't,
we weren't, we were not jocks.
As soon as I, I, you know,
I used to play a little baseball,
some basketball,
but as soon as I picked up
that base and I struggled,
I didn't want any of that stuff touching
my hands. My hands became precious.
But then I was a carpenter
for, you know, eight years,
beating the hell out of my hands.
So, how did you develop that?
How did you develop,
cause nobody like you.
So who did you listen to
that we will you actually,
I feel like if I had to guess,
we listening to a lot of non
bass players to get your ideas.
I was listening to pretty much everything.
But um,
when I first started it was guys,
it was definitely a Getty Lee and Chris
Squire and John Paul Jones and people
like that.
And then I got turned on to the Larry
Graham's and the Stanley Clarks and the
Louis Johnson's, you know, remember
Don Kirshner is rock concert.
Do you remember that name?
I know,
but that was a little bit for my tops know
MTV so late at night. That would be a,
there was um,
I want the midnight special,
I think it was called and
Don Kirschner's rock concert.
And that's what you watch those on
youtube. Like I discovered those,
like when youtube came out I was able
to go back and watch the chief critic on
Don Kirshner is and seeing the brothers
Johnson and there's Louis Johnson old
bucket. I was like, oh my God, what
the Hell is that? So here's a question.
How the fuck did you
figure out how to do that?
Because these kids nowadays that you
can just look up basically any song and
somebody will break down how to play it.
Um,
and sometimes it's actually the
guy who literally played it.
Like nowadays it'd be like
fucking John Bonham. Hey,
this is how I play that quick
little triplet thing. You
want to do this and blah,
blah, blah. Good luck mate. Whatever plays
bastards. I have it so much easier now.
I know.
And they're monsters.
You had to sit and just figure
it out or go see concerts,
which I didn't have any money, so it
was hard for me to even go see concerts,
but just plan it.
Just kind of,
that's why my style is the way
it is because it's, it's, it's,
there's no conventional
element to it besides,
I joined jazz band right around then
and my music teacher was shocked to find
out that I didn't know how to read music.
So he gave me this crash course on reading
music and I just was in the jazz band.
So that was the only real theory I ever,
we still know how to read music.
It just barely just,
yeah, you don't really,
I mean he hears it as good as they are.
You don't really need to do, I mean,
unless you're like a session guy,
right.
And not too many people are reading
music these days unless you're,
unless you're in the orchestra, like a
hipster thing to do in the music world.
What? Read music, you know, they
always do all the throwback shit.
You know what I mean? I have no
clue. I mean I would love to,
I wish my reading chops were better,
but I,
there's other things I'd rather do at
this point then Polish my reading jazz.
Well that's right because
you have your new album,
the catch south of reality and
that's a flea on the cover.
It actually learn what a flea looked like.
I never needed,
it was like some little thing
jumping off on my dog. Um,
with the Great Sean Lennon and you guys
are going to be touring is going to be a
US tour. You starting here in
the u s going up to Canada.
What are you doing and how we're doing?
I think we're doing three or
four tours this summer, so we're,
we're starting in a couple of weeks going
around the states and then we go out
with Jim James and then we go
out with the flaming lips saw.
That's awesome by the way. But
before we wrap this up here, um,
I love you bus by the Little
Rhonda. Oh my God. You have,
you bought like one of those old school
like Grey Hound look and buses that has
like the roof and then it goes up and it's
like the windows. Is that what it was?
It was it straight across?
Straight across.
It's a provost Privo say in
France. And what year is it? A,
it's an 87. Yeah, I knew it was an
old school. It's older than I was.
My wife said a handful of years ago.
Hey when I'm letting you know,
once the kids move out, I'm coming on
the road with you. And I said, all right,
well if you come on the road,
you're going to be selling some booze
cause we have a boutique wine label.
What's the name of it? Uh, purple
packet room. Claypool, sellers. Um,
but we make it's very nice.
Peanut like I would have brought you some,
I for some reason I didn't
think you drank. Uh,
cause you always catch me when I'm on the
wagon. I'm taking this year off. I uh,
you know the problem, what I did with
booze was I brought it into my house.
I let the devil in the house,
cause my thing is if it's there,
it's just like a gown ice cream.
There's a gallon ice cream,
I'm going to fucking eat it
and there's a bottle of booze,
I'm going to finish it.
And then, uh, the same way,
if I eat fast food than I create
fast food from drinking booze,
I just sort of crave it.
But,
so I just kinda got out of my house and
going to take the A, I want to be that.
I want to be that guy that has a glass of
wine with the, with the, with the meal.
And he's like, oh that was great. That
that was a nice a cultural mall coach.
Ramal Couteau mall to my meal and
then having to my house. So I have,
well I have a lot of ice cream. I
have, we do in the case of lasers.
Amazing, amazing wine. No, but that's
another thing though. Or it's an event.
It's the same thing with cigars.
I got him out of the house
cause I started smoking Cuban.
So you didn't go in the book cause I
went through a big cigar phase in many,
many years and I'm a humidor full of them.
There was only like 22
years old or something.
My thing about them is I find that,
uh,
with Cubans is so many of them,
their wraps so fucking tight that,
you know, like when he had like, um,
like when you were a kid and you had
like a shake or a malt or something like
that and you had it like almost suck
your brain out of the Bacchae it had just
to get it to come, I felt like malls.
Yeah. So it's like, you know, there's not,
it doesn't have, like, a lot
of them don't have a good draw.
It's a pain in the ass.
And this, there's some, um,
ones that I like more to Minuchin or
Nicaraguan cigars that I'm enjoying and
they're, they're not wrapped, you
know, balled up like a fist. I still,
but there's nothing better than
a Cuban with the good drop,
but like trying to find one,
someone gave me a Cuban the other
night and I was like, oh my God,
this is amazing. I was
just like, Jesus Christ,
fucking eyeballs are going to pop out of
my head trying to get a little mouthful
of smoke here. So, um, I like the
Aurora emeralds and then there's,
um, to say on the one, what the
fuck is it called? I can't remember.
I just know what that one, so you're
smoking like the big old Churchill's.
Are you sticking with a little,
you know, a, a fistful of dollars,
you know Clint Eastwood's style, not
the little ones. Ron White smokes those.
I've seen him smoke few of those and
he looks cool as hell. It's doing that,
but not,
I used to steal the old Tianwan of smalls
and Swisher sweets when I was a kid
and smoke them in the tree for
it. That was always, Oh, it,
my dad used to smoke the Dutch
master and then he wouldn't,
and he would always keep the box and
then in there went all the loose screws
and everything would go in
there, uh, inside the, uh,
whatever, the little kitchen drawer
there. So I told you, and you know,
I haven't been able to pull it off yet,
but my rode a bus that I want to
get is I want to get one of those,
you remember that, that uh, that GMC we,
you and I were sending back
and forth and I just, you know,
you're a busy guy and that one
with the blue leather interior,
that thing was cool. And I know, I know,
I know. I want to get, I just have to,
I have to work it out because what it is,
if I didn't have a fucking kid,
then I would be doing the road like an
animal and I could bring my wife along
and blah, blah, blah. But, you know,
I got this whole, I'm rooted now,
which is great and I love it.
But, um, are you rooted here? Yes.
And I love it out here.
The dream is I want to get one of those
definitely buddy who built my truck and
my dad's car.
Um,
Redo the thing and I'm sorry,
I'm trying to,
I'm going to Burp here. It's so much bad
food today, um, Turkey, but help you out.
Turkey. That's I needed to,
if this podcast was a tube,
my body would be thanking you right now.
Um,
I want to get that thing totally like
redone, like underneath, like to have,
it still looked like 1974,
1975 on underneath be like 2019.
And the thing that I would add to it was
I would have a humor door and then it
would just be like my,
my vice mobile so I wouldn't
do anything when I was home,
which is most of the days now. And
I only do, I do to two runs a month.
So I'd be like, you know, and just like
one, one night on each run I would go hot,
you know? Well I, I had my face off and
then that would be like times 12 months.
That's 24 days a year. I got drunk,
gives a shit my lever. But you know,
my doctor, my family. But other
than that, who gives a shit? Right.
Well, I mean there's many things
in that. That's a big statement.
One is you can drink, you don't
have to get drunk. I mean,
I drank the wine because
I enjoy it every night.
And that's called being mature and
you know, with some little subtle,
some beef Jerky, it's all
good. Um, and then, uh,
set the of the region. I see.
I'm that guy. I'm the, I'm the,
if you're looking for a vehicle,
an older vehicle,
I am the guy because I always tell
people I don't do social media.
My version of social media is going on
craigslist and looking for old car parts
and I'm not bullshitting.
I'm always looking for Chrysler parts.
I'm looking for this.
And then the next thing,
so when I hear somebody
who's looking for something,
and I did do a little digging for you
at that time and then I forgot, but um,
I used to have a 23 foot birch
haven GMC. The 23 is, well,
there's the table. Something's happened.
I just noticed it's 23 in the 20th.
This is the 26.
And then there's the 23 to 23 is or are
cool because you can take them into most
campgrounds that don't normally allow RVs.
And um,
the birch havens where the only the
birch havens and the royals were the ones
that actually have real
wood interior. So I'm, oh,
I remember you sent me all of that
stuff. Yeah, it's a whole, it's a whole
subset. Yeah. And there's websites
about these things. They're,
they're amazing race
and when you drive them,
it's like driving a Cadillac and the
way the windshield wraps around you,
it's almost like you're sitting on
the bumper, you know, it's, yeah,
it's really incredible rigs now with a
few times I've done tours and I rented a
bus or anything.
The thing that I did love about that was,
uh, first of all the guys
that I toured with a toward,
with three of my great buddies and like,
it was like,
he was so excited to do the show
and you'd pull up in the bus,
it was fucking awesome.
And then you'd go and you'd do the show.
You'd have a great time.
And then we would get on the bus and
you'd be so excited and we'd put in like,
good fellows are anchorman
or something like that.
And we would just sit there laughing
the whole night. Um, you know,
drinking and eating and just watching
movies. And it was like the, uh,
the comradery on it was, was, was
incredible. And I, and I kind of,
I do miss that. And a, I have
to figure out a way I've been,
I've been toying with
it because my thing is,
I think I want to do it is to just hire
a driver and then he just has it and he
just a different thing than getting the,
the GMC right. I mean, not in Chino,
but I want to get the GMC
and just have the guy had,
he just has the fucking thing and I say
it right. And it's just like, all right,
here's my tour goes from here to
here because the pluses, buses,
that's a whole different level that's
like, you know, million dollar rigs.
And they were amazing.
And that's why I don't do it
anymore because when I got the bill,
it was like Jesus Christ,
because he was still, you know,
drivers go and you want to
leave tonight. I was like, yeah,
let's get the fucking
drive out of the way.
I didn't realize I was paying
overtime, so I already paid. I was,
I already won one gig and a half is out
the fucking window and then the bill
came. You know what I mean?
It's like, you know, you know,
it was like fucking stop playing them
Chinese joint. Yeah, you can step it up.
Well, anyways, uh, the album
is called south. The reality,
you don't know where they can get it.
I'm assuming that you can get
it on iTunes and all that.
It's like psychedelic music.
It's too incredible.
Musician Sean Lennon and the Les Claypool.
Thank you for doing my
podcast and thank you for,
we go on three solid decades
of incredible music and uh,
I love everything that
you do. Um, Tim Alexander,
one of my favorite drummers of all time,
brain, everybody that you play with.
I just, I just loved the
musicians that you work with.
So I'm going to be downloading
this, uh, when I get home. Well My,
if my wife teaches me how to do it, there
you go. I will definitely be doing it.
So a look for the tour.
Three tours, right?
So far. Yeah. Oh, by the way, I'm
so I've got to read an ad here.
You want to see something inspirational?
I'm watch. Watch me try to read out loud.
All right. Oh, look who it
is. It's my bookie. Yay.
I get Dolan brackets first round upsets.
Still Final Four.
March madness is here and it's time
to bet with the best at my bookie.
Uh, would you rather sit at your
office desk or call out sick?
And I love this degenerate shit
that's been, yeah, blow off work.
Call out sick and binge on the NCAA
tournament games and junk food.
Like that's even a choice.
Sometimes it feels good to be bad.
These guys are wonderful, especially
when it's with someone you trust.
You either already saying fake sick and
now they're going to act like they're
trustworthy. And if you're looking
for a place to get in on the action,
you can trust my bookie.
They've been in the business for years
and they're growing like wildfire.
The best part is they pay out fast.
So when you called that 12, uh,
over five upset this year, I what
that means, make sure to celebrate.
You'll be pocketing cold hard cash
here in under the core talking points.
March madness is the most exciting action
patch pack, sporting event of the year.
Even grandmothers fill out a bracket.
My mother does,
she picked holy cross a couple
of years ago. You play, you win,
you get paid or you lose, you get
evicted and you suck. Dick. Okay,
I'm just just being devil advocate
here, right? Only at my bookie. Dot.
A G and A.
I actually now you can listen to a little,
a 15 minute clip of me on the radio
show talking with some of the guys about
some of my picks and then listen to a
classic job Thursday afternoon just before
Friday,
Monday morning
podcast to follow.
Thank you guys so much for listening
and thank you again for all the great
stories, uh, and all the wonderful
music. All right, les Claypool,
everybody's Les Claypool south of reality,
Berlin, the sports gave me back. Gas is
brought to you by my bunkie. Dot. Agee.
My book is the leader
in online sports books.
Use the Promo Code bill bets
for a 50% deposit bonus.
Play when and get paid.
And My bookie. Dot.
Aga joining us on the my bookie dot.
Agee hotline,
the one and the only bill burr bill.
It's march madness. Are you, uh,
are you one of those guys who
fills out a bunch of brackets?
Are you going to fill out a bracket?
I used to be that guy.
I got a kid now.
So between watching like
the Mickey Mouse Club,
been a puppy dog pals.
Feel your pain there.
I feel your pain.
The kids had been out of
town for like four days,
so I'm just immersed myself
in college basketball.
It's awesome
to watch hockey or chalking watch
basketball. She knows how to do this,
but then like about three minutes,
then she's just like, oh, watch
out pass.
So I essentially only one,
she was highly life [inaudible] career
him blowing out the spanker and all of
that out. You know, it was blown up,
shot our shops and continuing
to go up after he blocked it.
Yeah.
He uh,
he blew out his shoe and he
also kind of hurt his knee.
And then there was this big debate
in the, you know, amongst the sports,
like talking heads,
whether or not Zion Williamson should
come back or just rest the rest of the
year and miss out on the tournament.
It's pretty cool.
Now go ahead boo.
I
stay and,
and not have conversations like that.
Just basically getting
filthy rich.
Yeah. And I think, you know, I think we're
going to, we're, we're close to that.
They can't keep, continue this
charade of like amateur athletics,
but we're going to sign billion dollar
contracts with the TV networks. I mean,
specifically I like, how's
ions? Kinda like, Nah man,
I want to play ball with my
friends. Like back up, you know,
I'll make some money in the future.
But I do think it's funny that everyone
had to have an opinion about this,
what this kid wanted to do and he's like,
well my kid and want to play basketball
with these dudes who I'm friends with.
So it's the, at the very least they
should just let them, you know,
make money off their own name.
You know,
if there was a guy on a mass scholarship
and Sun and Sunlight compass company
wanted to pay him a bunch of money or
a graphing calculator company wanted to
pay a bunch of money to MDUs that graphing
calculator that the school wouldn't
have a shot and there's an amateur
athlete please. It's just, it's just,
cause the colleges aren't,
wouldn't be getting a cut of that.
And they already had these shoe
deals. That's, that's the real issue.
The beginning of
television and then the Internet
streaming and all of that. And
I want
to
listen to the coach and
you know I was watching, I'm going to
say the guy that much in this team,
this team is playing.
He comes back and it's just all about
him so they started to kind of discuss it
and one of the,
one of the teller commentators don't,
well you have to understand that when you
get a player of his caliber he's going
to have to get,
he's touching
my team still
with nobody underneath.
Nobody's getting whole team.
It's just really near the completely,
she has different game
but it just sucks when they don't pay
the kids and then also get to see coach k
develop a guy like Zion for just
one year as opposed to like,
I don't think like the last big
guy that stayed four years was a,
what's his face from the stores
just blanked on his name.
He stayed for a while. For sure. Yeah.
I do think there's that element of
like I want to root for these guys.
You're after.
I mean part of the reason you like
rooting for a protein to like that's going
away. It is. It is becoming,
I feel like the millennial culture and
plenty of people have talked about this
specifically in basketball,
they root for players now,
like Odell Beckham would be a
good, good, good choice too.
I know a lot of people are getting
Brown's jerseys cause they're back.
It's like what is this nonsense for
your team? You support your city,
defend the shield.
Never gonna open up
the wallet to get those kids to stay
compared to what they would make as prose.
Yeah. I mean even if they go
in my business, if I sell out
at the end of the day,
yeah, right. You're
bringing the entire crowd.
It's the Fab five thing. Jalen rose, Chris
Weber or walking down the street, the,
this,
the college is making tons of money.
They're selling their
jerseys for $100 a pipe,
but they don't have enough money
to pay for it. Like that's,
it feels like you could very
quickly fixed that by saying,
if we sell as Diane Williams Jersey,
you get a piece of this period.
Yeah.
Billions of dollars. Uh, you know,
especially with like football
has to physical or the offense.
And the defense and all that.
You didn't have time to like be going
to class and all of that type of stuff.
I mean,
it is what it is.
And the reason why those schools have
all those beautiful buildings is because
of the sports programs. So I mean
they, they should be getting a,
I dunno, so be getting a
little something I would think.
Yeah. We know it's all
those chemistry a advocates,
they're donating hundreds of millions
of dollars to build buildings. It is a,
as a transparent, then
you're going to have this genius genius,
I should say
goodwill hunting kid. And He, uh,
solve the math problem that there's not
like a big ESPN Saidman on it. Right.
That would be hilarious if
people walked around with Jersey,
Asian kid on the back.
He's figured out the first 31 trillion.
It's like,
who gives a shit?
Yeah.
It's funny to watch those, those kids at
Turner awkward just like freaking out.
Oh man,
this spelled correctly.
It's somewhere between
a blooper reel stopper.
It's definitely a novelty thing that
people are watching for comedic.
Like they don't play the highlights on
sports center because they want to show
some awesome words. They really
just want to make fun of these kids.
It's kind of wanting to,
do you want to have some gift of some
kids sweating and it's like facial
reactions in his glasses and uh, yeah,
that's what they're looking for. Not,
not the celebration of scaling
freaking
out.
Yeah. It's like a, it's a more
intelligent approach to wheel of fortune.
Oh, absolutely. I can't figure out
a bill as
a basketball team has
always been the canvas.
They are definitely one of the teams
that people are throwing out as.
Don't be surprised if Kansas takes an
early exit from the tournament this year.
They have, they have some, uh,
they've had some issues all year and I
think there were what? Sean unforeseen.
Yeah, they're taking on north.
Northeastern, yeah. There,
there are four c going up against the 13.
[inaudible].
This was the first year that in the big
12 tournament they weren't a number one
seed. So every I probably 14 years
since they didn't win the conference.
I think. Yeah, it's been a crazy
year off for them. But those are,
those are sometimes a teams you have to
be on the lookout for as far as bedding
on teams with that kind of history
that maybe just had a down year in the
regular season, solid coaching, they can
kind of turn it on and make a run. I mean,
that's how I kind of think
Villanova is going to do.
They've won two in the last
four national championships.
They didn't have a great regular season,
but they played well winning the big east.
I think they could make a little bit
of noise. So yeah, just to tie it up,
Kansas is playing northeastern and the
first round minus six and a half point
favorite. So people still
liking Kansas, I think, right?
Not,
not northeastern box.
Yeah. Yeah. Oh yeah. They
in it. We, we, you know,
because we were going to talk to you.
I looked through it. I come through it.
I'm like,
what's Boston teams are going to be in
the northeastern is the only Boston and a,
yeah, they won whatever
time conference. They're in
Kansas. Jayhawks oh, all I gotta
go. I gotta go northeastern though.
All right,
so you're going to northeastern,
so you're not a millennial who's
just going to follow players.
You gotta stick it, stick to
the, the home. The home grown.
Nice.
I like it.
So maybe,
yeah,
maybe ride the huskies have bill burr
catching six and a half points bill
that Wednesday.
Thursday.
It starts tomorrow morning. I think the
first game tips at nine 15 Pacific time.
Northeastern Kansas is going
to be at 1:00 PM tomorrow.
Uh, that's got cigar bar written
all over it. All right. I love it.
Go huskies as a, uh, as a
comedian, you know, it's,
it's easy to get annoyed. I think
I had, uh, you know, the, the,
the announcers when they try and be funny.
I think the one exception though
is Charles Barkley. Are you, uh,
are you a huge fan of
watching Barkley as a, uh,
as a color commentator or a analyst?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a lot of great ones.
Time you've talked about
some stupid thing.
Nothing to do with the game.
The coach is trying to
figure out is his tendencies.
I'd love Tony Romo.
Well,
I just love that he waited.
He saves his greatness for after he was
done playing football for the Dallas
cowboys.
So I do
is that owner who looks like he should,
that guy stepped in in the
beginning when he got Jimmy Johnson,
Jamie was getting all that credit
elevator going down the field.
They problem is the owner. It was not
only wrong, but he's the quarterback.
So he took all the brunt.
Yes, he does have a Montgomery
Burns type vibe, a Jerry Jones
seat elevator to get down to the,
well,
we can run out there and get some
face time when they went that that's,
that's not saying in your own way.
Yeah, that is a, I mean that's a
horrible move going on the sidelines.
Just ask Arthur blank of the Atlanta
Falcons when they were on the 28 to three
and he goes down there with his wife and
they're holding the hands as the lead
slowly slips away and the
paths go all the way back.
And when an OT that's you just, you
gotta stay in the state of your buttocks
right up there with watching somebody
on Sunday playing the masters.
There's nothing like showing
it does because it takes, so
he missed his game over like,
I mean, do you remember the Greg Norman
show job where it was like, well, I mean,
I remember as a kid watching
this guy has completely
ruining his life right now.
He looked like a guy in a public course.
Yeah, no, I mean, I was going
to say that's what happens when,
when you're playing a four summit to bell
and Burbank and you're playing with a
guy who just freaks out
and I'm the third holy,
he's throwing his clubs and it's like,
all right, well this isn't gonna go well,
who is that guy I saw like
10 years ago for the
first time I was like,
I'm going to watch the masters
from Thursday through Sunday.
I watched the whole thing
does it Kenny Perry?
Oh that.
No.
What the hell was his name
when he fell down a scorecard. You
can, you can talk to his family.
He just got in this car and
started driving and that's it. Then
we're going to be like a hoarder's.
You walk by that and then you go on the
golf course. That's like the best buy.
It just looks like a regular, you know,
strip mall. So the Internet, so he left
and then just drive it down.
It's funny you say that.
What are the worst things I ever saw?
Yeah, you're right. It was Kenny Perry.
It was 2009 so stellar memory
10 years ago did collapse.
I've also been to Augusta and yeah,
it's,
it's Kinda like when you visit a very
prestigious university that's dropped in
the middle of a bad part
of town and there's just,
you walk through security game,
you walk through gates, uh,
Georgia tech and he went like this.
The USC is a little bit,
you walk through some gates
and all of a sudden you're,
the grass is green and things
are nice and you're like,
what the fuck's going on here?
Yeah,
kind of makes you think
about society a little bit.
You go on the outside of the gate to the
Augusta and at strip malls and barbecue
joints like that.
That's all there is now.
They call it discussed
the for a reason shown.
It's funny you mentioned that Hooters
because uh, every year at that Hooters,
John Daly shows up in a RV and just
hangs out at the Hooters parking live and
just signs autographs and
talks about his crazy days.
What a life that guy has.
No, he's really on top of it.
He's one of the
longest drive torque
and the head of his card
laugh, like I'm watching a stand
up real fight at how this don't,
just the raw power and
just having that all set
for going out and partying the night
before and saying like, he's, you know,
he's too tired or whatever.
And he just finally looked at him aside.
He was playing pickup Jordan Jordan
cocktails on the golf course.
Lawrence Taylor.
That was the opposite.
Well, John Daly had a
great, uh, he, he was in,
he was doing an interview and he
explained that he had trouble putting,
because every time he would go to Putt,
as he was pulling the club head back,
he would start thinking about how
much he owes his wife in alimony.
He was paying her $35,000 a month. He
goes, I can't hit a damn pot anymore.
All I do is thinking about
how much money I owe or
so sad. Yeah. Sunday comes around to that.
No alimony and child support.
Maybe one day daily. We'll get some of
that money back. A bill. Before we go,
just your thoughts on NFL free
agency or the NFL off season.
The Oda Big Odell Beckham Trade,
Antonio Brown.
He didn't want to play for the bills
and he ended up getting traded to the
Raiders.
Levy up balance.
Yes.
Okay.
I didn't want to play there and then it's
just like he gets to go somewhere else.
John Elway,
all of those guys.
I won't say,
I won't say with an NFL quarterback
because if people don't look bad and they
have no offensive line, like your
career's going to be over like all that.
Like the Joey Harrington, he
said, well that guy was a bus.
It's like you got thoughts.
He went to the lions.
Who knows what he could have been.
He wasn't running for his life for
three years. So I don't know. I think I
may feel swagger and a gal,
his emotional issues or whatever,
they're kind of becoming the
mid West Oakland Raiders,
so maybe that'll work if they can get a
bunch of free spirits in there as they
say. Um, I think,
I think him and Baker Mayfield are going
to be great together and I think it's,
it's exciting just to see Brown
fans excited. I'm happy for that.
I do agree with that.
I,
I do find it interesting that we as a
country feel sorry for Cleveland and
always want to prop them up when
there's an opportunity. But yeah,
it does seem like Odell Beckham walking
into the browns locker room is like the
dude smoking the cigarette, walking
through a gas station. It May, may, may,
may turn into nothing,
but it also may turn it into a
whole very awesome situation.
Watch it come down a and Jarvis
Landry, he's, no, he's no wallflower.
That guy blast them and it's supposedly
he's best friends with Odell so maybe
they make it work.
But he's,
he's a guy who loves getting the ball
and it's going gonna make that a point.
So if Baker can kind of battery,
I hope it goes to the positive way and
then they become like this hilarious,
you know,
exciting team to watch that has like the
best interviews afterwards cause they
all say a bunch of crazy stuff.
That's what I'm hoping for.
Well and the networks are clamoring to
get Cleveland browns games this year. So
multiple Cleveland Brown games in
prime time. It's been a long time.
My uncle, my uncle is going to roll
over in his grave. But you got,
I mean the browns fans in general,
Cleveland is a real legit sports city.
Any team has so many die hards,
whether it's the browns or the bills
teams that maybe the city doesn't have a
lot going on besides the team. You
got root for those, those fan bases.
So it's good to see they're getting
some big time players in their bill.
As always,
appreciate you calling in to the podcast.
Make sure you check out bill's a Monday
morning podcast. F is for family.
Anything else you got going on bill
now streaming on Netflix?
It's an adult cartoon.
I would say definitely some vulgar
language and Scott, a lot of heart.
I don't watch it around your kids.
We've got three great seasons and we're
wrapping up season four right now as far
as writing it and season
four should be out next year.
A quick sidebar to that.
Uh,
one of my kids fat stumbled across F F
F is for family and I had that moment
where I was like, no, stop.
But it is funny. Great show,
great says.
Yeah.
You guys just parents decide your own
what you're going to do with your kid
watching it.
I'm not a big fan of censorship,
but I may be applied a little sensor show.
You got it.
You got to figure out the right edge.
All right. Thanks. All
right guys. We'll see you.
All right.
Appreciate it.
[inaudible].